my leading lady
my leading lady in the picture we
recently completed is one of our happier
imports from Europe a bright talented
and sexy blond beauty named elke sommer
she's here this evening with the only
man in town her husband will trust with
her that dapper debonair dandy Don
Knotts
Here I am again I am here to present the
short subjects award and I'm a short
subject
and while being with Alfie is my award
Don you're very nice thank you oh well
not only that but off-screen I'm really
very tall an extremely handsome would
you begin please it's for the best
achievement insured subjects there are
two categories categories categories
live-action and cartoons oral yes and
for life actions the nominees are the
chicken look fully rent reductions
Claude berry producer fortress of peace
both are wolf productions for farmer
loser films Lothar wolf producer scatter
data by way productions marshal Bechtler
and no black produces snow British
Transport films in association with
Jeffrey Jones films
Edgar Anstey producer timepiece Muppets
incorporated Jim Henson producer there
we have the seal results please
the winner is the chicken flawed buddy
excepting for club Barry Gerry Purcell
for clogged Barry who is in Paris
thank you
before we get to the cartoons okay do
you have a date for the ball tonight
yes ahead well let's get on with the
cartoons nominations are clay or the
Origin of Species Harvard University
Eliot Noyes junior producer the dot and
the line metro-goldwyn-mayer Chuck Jones
and less goldman producers the thieving
magpie la Gazza Ladra a Julia Giannini
Emmanuelle lazatti production the manual
is re producer let mr. nuts
open the envelope please the winner is
the dot and the line chuck jones let's
go
great deal has been said in favor of the
idea that films are bigger than ever we
feel that occasionally somewhere it can
be said for films being smaller than
ever
Norton jesters book the dot no lie and
we felt was a delightful small book and
I'd like to particularly thank those
people who against all temptation is
fought to keep it small
I'd like to Maurice Noble to Eugene
progeny and of all things to Robert
Morley
thank you very much it's a rare and
privileged time when a major studio goes
way out and backs a strange and wild
entertainment film like the doc malign
and I want to thank the MGM management
for being with us all the way and of
course all the members of the Academy
thank you